speaking of january 6 hysterics we're
learning exclusively tonight about
what's going on inside the fbi well
whistleblowers have told congressman jim
jordan that the agency is in full-blown
retaliation mode
referring to what's going on as a purge
of agency employees
who hold conservative views one employee
reportedly had a security clearance
taken away and then he was indefinitely
suspended from his duty and got his pay
taken away for disagreeing with their
january 6 narrative ohio congressman jim
jordan ranking member of the house
judiciary committee joins me now
congressman
now this specific fbi employee i
mentioned yeah um what can you tell us
more about him or her
decorated iraqi war veteran being run
out of the fbi his allegiance to the
country is being questioned because he
had he had the the gall to say something
that offended the fbi leadership about
the january 6 investigation the other
one is also
having the same thing happen to them
simply because on an anonymous
questionnaire they said something that
the leadership disagreed with them about
january 6. and i would put out point out
laura that we now have had six agents
come forward as whistleblowers two on
the school board's narrative school on
the school boards issue and four now
regarding january 6. that is a concern
to us but we've had literally a half a
dozen fbi agents come to our committee
uh it's happening all over government is
it not jim i mean it's happening at the
fbi we know it's happening in our
military with the whole stand down order
remember in
the spring of 2021 after january 6. so
we have to make sure there are no like
unsavory people in our military that was
a warning shot that they fired across
the bow for our young military men and
women was it not
right exactly it's the weaponization of
government against your political foes
the legacy and to go with your monologue
the legacy of the attorney general
garland right now is the school board's
issue writing the memorandum that treats
moms and dads as domestic terrorists
that's the legacy thus far in his in his
tenure as as attorney general but this
weaponization of government against your
political foes is exactly what's going
so much so we had the disinformation
governance board and but for your
efforts and others pointing this out
that still might be an operation that is
how the left is opera in the context
here with with the fbi remember a few
years ago they spied on president trump
then it was the actions they took
against parents regarding the school
board situation
and then two whistleblowers last month
had come forward who attended the
january 6 rally on their own time with
their spouse didn't go in the capital
haven't been charged but they've had
their security clearance taken from them
too which is always the first step in
termination again one of those
individuals was also a veteran in our
armed forces this is happening and it is
as wrong as wrong can be now congressman
on the issue of jan 6
here's the cnn reporter ryan nobles
with i thought what was a stunning
admission watch
it's largely going to be a controlled
message even though there are
republicans on the panel
these republicans and democrats are
working in unison that means there's
going to be no opposition voices during
these hearings
i mean that is laugh out loud hilarious
jim i mean this is theater and they're
upset that we're not running running it
live on fox it's their theater it's
their production it's their props their
wardrobe their makeup whatever the hell
they're doing it's all on them that's
what they wanted and they've
yeah and they've used taxpayer money to
hire the former president of abc news to
choreograph the documentary that they're
going to present on thursday night and
over the coming weeks so yeah this is
exactly what it is choreographed brought
to you by the the taxpayer at taxpayer
expenses how much is costing by the way
congressman we have mothers who can't
find baby formula all right we have
people struggling to put fuel in their
gas tanks how much is this costing this
little show i don't i don't know but i
do know you're right there will be no
cross this is the only committee hearing
i've ever seen in congress where there
was not an opportunity to cross-examine
witnesses because there is no republican
on that committee who will do it so this
is worse than what adam schiff did in
the bunker in the basement with
impeachment back in 2019 at least i got
to be in that room and depose witnesses
and then when they had the hearings we
got to cross-examine witnesses but in
this situation that's not even happening
so this is completely choreographed
presentation completely partisan the
good news is the american people have
figured all that out yeah kafka would be
very proud congressman great to see you